non mais j'aimerais vraiment qu'il le
soit c'est pas par sectarisme parce que
le président n'est pas de mon bord
j'adorerais dire je suis ravie mais
quand on parle de transfert de
compétences sans annoncer de transfert
financier je veux bien être responsable
de compétences nouvelles qu'on transfert
Rennes et sans argent on fait comment
quand on nous dit on va décentraliser
mais on crée 35 nouveaux postes de
sous-préfet histoire de bien alourdir la
technocratie d'État quand on nous dit
faut éviter d'artificialisation des sols
on est tous d'accord mais que l'État
nous demande à côté avec la loi Stru de
construire des logements enfin le tout
et son contraire j'ai beaucoup de mal
avec ça alors si c'est enrobé après de
canin en disant vous êtes vraiment
formidable mais qui a rien de concret
oui c'est sûr que pour moi le contenait
pas moi je demande pas de me faire la
cadinothérapie je demande de me donner
les moyens de mon action de répondre à
l'intérêt général et surtout d'aller
voir ce que c'est qu'un territoire
quand il nous dit pour éviter
l'artificialisation des sols vous avez
qu'à construire sur des friches moi chez
moi il y en a pas forcément des friches
donc il y a pas des friches partout faut
aller voir à quoi ça ressemble un
territoire français donc parfois
j'aimerais qu'il un peu moins hors sol
est-ce qu'il y a eu un point positif
quand même sur le la sécurité des mers
là
ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'on mette le
paquet sur l'école alors j'ai tendu
l'oreille il a commencé à dire sur
l'éducation c'est un sujet fondamental
etc il a parlé d'investissement dans les
écoles sur le bâtiment c'est très bien
et moi j'attends surtout un choc de
société pour vraiment extraire de
l'école tous des problèmes sociétaux qui
sont dedans on peut le faire en donnant
plus de prérogatives aux mères en
permettant en mer d'avoir des conseils
des droits et devoir des familles ou des
familles sont convoquées quand il y a
des problèmes on donne plus de
prérogatives au directeurs
d'établissement enfin il y aurait des
réformes de société profondes à faire
pour que l'école change ça n'a pas été
annoncé ce soir en fait il y a pas de il
y a un catalogue de poncifs il y a
beaucoup de constats sur le fait que la
société mute échange bah ça oui on avait
remarqué on est bien content on peut
faire une thérapie collective une fois
qu'on a dit ça moi j'attends la
président de la République qui me donne
une vision et qui donne une vision pour
la société demain et pour et pour ma
gosse donc je n'ai pas eu ça ce soir
en fait vous savez ce n'est pas grâce à
eux c'est grâce au Sénat je remercie
vraiment les sénateurs les sénateurs ont
torpillé toutes les mesures les plus
restrictives qui pénalisaient des
collectivités territoriales et comme ils
peuvent pas se permettre à nouveau 49-3
et bien en réalité le Sénat va être
suivi moi je peux vous faire vous savez
c'est comme dans les films quand il y a
sous-titres de sous-titrage de des
bonnes nouvelles en matière de
financement des collectivités c'est
surtout grâce au Sénat parce qu'ils
avaient en fait mis énormément de
contraintes dans le texte qui fait que
très peu de communes en réalité étaient
concernés par les bonnes nouvelles donc
merci à nos sénateurs et puis tant mieux
si au moins les sénateurs sont entendus
merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]